dozens of Asylum Seekers held at the
manston processing center in Kent have
contracted diphtheria with one man
thought to have died from the disease
concerns have been raised after reports
suggest some had been moved to other
parts of the UK without being properly
screened joining us now is the GP Dr
David Lloyd hello to Dr Lloyd it's
always great to see you thanks for
joining us what is diphtheria
oh diphtheria is a is a really horrid
disease I've never seen a case I don't
think any in my generation really have
but I remember my father talking about
it it you get a huge white membrane
going over the back of the throat which
means you can't breathe and sometimes
you need to have a tube put in you also
have a very swollen neck they call it a
bull neck and you're very very ill and
uh and unless you get treatment very
quickly it can be a very deadly disease
there is a small there is a minor
variant where people who are exposed to
it for a long time get a skin condition
to a horrible rotten skin ulcers so yes
it's a horrible disease we haven't had
it really in any quantities since the
1940s when we started vaccinating so I
guess the key thing is do make sure all
your children are up to date with their
vaccinations you need five to five lots
of vaccinations to keep diphtheria at
the bay but this is a very hot political
issue and so I you're asking me I'm
afraid for medical things so I don't
dare say one way or the other but uh
some sides of this argument are saying
that we're suddenly inundated with uh
with diphtheria others are saying that
there's very little but we all travel
thousands of miles every year there's uh
uh and so we all have a chance of
bringing that this disease back from
countries that don't vaccinate against
diphtheria so so but if we are
vaccinated against it you know if if you
know I'm guessing most of the country is
uh inoculated against uh dip Syria so
how much of a risk is it for the general
population well that's exactly right so
we rely on the vaccinations to keep up
our immunity
um but there is as there is so little
depth to dip theory of circulating in
the community we don't have any natural
immunities so as we get older that
immunity can die down and unless we've
had the full course we are at risk so
this is yet another plug I'm afraid for
mothers and fathers getting their
children vaccinated and completing the
whole course if we meet people who've
come from another country particularly
refugees and we're not sure of their
vaccination history we will give them a
complete cause to get 11 catch up
are you suggesting that older people
should potentially be going to the
doctor to say oh I'm not sure if I've
had all my inauguration no I'm not no
I'm just saying that there is a
theoretical dropping off in immunity but
I don't think you're going to come
across much diphtheria whatever age you
are it just means that us doctors have
got to just put this in the list of
things that cause sore throats and once
you look in someone's throat and you see
this infection they even even me you
could diagnose diphtheria I think yeah
um talk to me about scabies Apparently
that is another subject that we're
hearing quite a lot about at the moment
how worried should we be about scabies
well it's not deadly and
for Roses ferocious itch
unless you get the right treatment you
do itch for weeks and weeks and months
and months but there is very effective
treatment for it and as long as you obey
the rules and apply the ointment you
make a complete recovery but yes again
crowding in unsanitary conditions can
spread scabies like welfare but you
can't catch it unless you're you sleep
in the sheets of somebody who's caught
it or in very close contact with them so
you've got to be pretty close and pretty
intimate to catch it otherwise okay
covid
um where are we with covid at the moment
it seems like people are dropping like
flies
uh well of course we are because it's
circulating so fast in the community and
we can't keep up with the variants
um but yes you've just everybody's got
to be very Vigilant
and if you're suspecting it get tested
uh and if you're at risk the key thing
is uh dial 119 because we've got a
fantastic system now for getting the uh
antibody serums and the nmabs to people
who are at risk from getting
complications of covid and the system is
very slick now so any dance at all ring
119 and we will sort you out
but are you finding that people are
being as poorly with covert as they were
previously no it's a it's
as I said last week so we've got
everybody getting flu-like illnesses
from the the three main infections that
are soaking in the community nowadays
but there are people with lots of risk
factors who are immunosuppressed who
will get complications and they I
hopefully have had a full course of
vaccines but I hopefully will contact
the right authorities so they can get
the uh the right treatment and we have
very good treatment we must let you go
um but thanks for your expertise as
always thank you